Bernardino became the richest man in the
world and what's crazy is he only sells
to one percent of the population you may
not have heard of Bernardino but I
guarantee you've heard of his companies
Louis Vuitton Christian Dior Celine
Sephora DKNY Bulgari Givenchy Tiffany
Hennessy Marc Jacob while the tech
billionaires and everyone's net worth
have plummeted Elon Musk lost 200
billion dollars Bezos lost 70. he only
lost seven his business model is
Recession Proof the man who's selling
ten thousand dollar purses there are
some lessons that we can learn from the
richest man in the world so the first
thing we have to understand is the
psychology of the rich versus the
psychology of the poor the first
encounter I had with like super wealth I
remember I was working at Smoothie King
I was a blender tender one of my buddies
he's in the back with his feet up he's
flipping through a magazine he's like
dude check this out this guy bought a 50
000 Burger man that's crazy who would
spend fifty thousand dollars on a burger
I thought about it more and more if I go
and get lunch it cost me 12 bucks for
the burger the fries and the coke
whatever he had said it was some Finance
guy who had made like 100 dollars that
year if he made 100 million dollars and
he worked 2 000 hours he made fifty
thousand dollars an hour I was making
seven dollars an hour and my burger cost
me 12 bucks his fifty thousand dollar
burger was cheaper for him for his
amount of money that he was making than
my twelve dollar lunch was for me that
was a huge shift for me where I realized
I'm playing this game wrong and I'm not
empathizing with the rich because he's
got to be thinking differently than I am
to be able to afford a fifty thousand
dollar burger it also kind of makes
sense for him the second is how we
create products that specifically serve
rich people they think differently and
want different things the best thing to
do is study luxury Brands when you shop
at a high-end store they'll offer you
champagne while you shop you're going to
have somebody who's assigned to you the
moment you walk in the door what can I
get for you they can have and deliver
that better experience because of the
premium and luxury prices they charge if
you've ever been to a luxury mall and
you see a purse for ten thousand dollars
and you see a jacket for fifty thousand
dollars and I would urge you to not say
those people are ridiculous I can't
believe someone would spend money on
that what I want you to do is actually
empathize with the buyer what kind of
person would spend fifty thousand
dollars on a jacket if I can pick from
all jackets and I have so much money
that the difference between a hundred
dollar jacket and a 50 000 jacket in
relative terms is a ten dollar
difference to me and my wealth then I
just want the best jacket Bernard or no
capitalized on this so there's four
distinct positions you can have in any
Marketplace you can have bargain which
is the absolute cheapest one poor
quality poor experience the next is best
value this is the difference between a
Walmart and a Target Target is better
value it's got brighter lights it's
cleaner it's the best value for the buck
the third position the marketplace is
premium the high-end Lexus the BMW and
then the fourth position in the
marketplace is luxury where the price
has no cap part of the value of the
product itself is the cost that people
know you paid to get it Bernardino lives
in this luxury bubble it's where people
associate their status with the purchase
they made typically when you raise
prices you decrease volume but in luxury
goods when you raise prices you increase
how many you sell and that creates this
unbelievable amount of profit which is
what has now propelled him to be the
single richest man in the world rich
people have the same problems that poor
people do they just want them solved
differently the big thing we want is we
want to deliver a big dream outcome
number two we want them to believe with
very high confidence that if they work
with us they're going to get what we
promised on the bottom side they want it
to be incredibly fast so as soon as they
pay they want to get and then they want
to have as little effort and sacrifice
assumingly possible and with the rich
speed and convenience are Paramount the
money is never an issue it's how much
are you going to ask of my time and how
painful are you going to make this for
me A buddy of mine only Services Fortune
100 companies and he manages right now
1.2 billion dollars a year in
advertising budget and here's what's
crazy his advertising agency actually
has to front the ad spend if they say
hey for this month in December I needed
to drop 300 million on Facebook ads he
has to front the 300 million but the
thing is is that he has to do it that
way because he needs to be as easy as
humanly possible so he actually has to
have a revolving credit line in the
billions with a bank he charges six
percent of all advertising dollars so
when they drop 300 million he gets six
percent not bad he gets 18 million bucks
just for fronting the cash rich people
will always pay for Speed the easiest
way to appeal to the rich is just do the
same thing in half the time whatever the
service is if it's dry cleaning return
it by end of day if you only have a
phone number be the person that can
accept anything if they email you shoot
you a text if they WhatsApp you if they
phone call you can accept anything
because you've made it convenient they
just want it to be effortless the third
is if we know what products and services
they want how to price those things
appropriately when you solve rich people
problems you get to charge rich people
prices when you deal with rich people
you have unlimited upside which is why
they are better customers there's five
things I want to talk about from the
customer's perspective because if you
increase the quality of your customers
you increase the quality of your
business number one when you charge more
money for your products or Services you
get an increased emotional investment if
you have a very low cost item people
won't even give it the time of day and
so when you raise the price you raise
their emotional investment and in a real
way you actually increase the likelihood
that they get results the second way
that it'll help your customers is that
it will increase their perceived value
there was a research study where they
had three bottles of wine they had a
cheap wine a mid-price wine and the
expensive one they had people try them
out and they had them rank them based on
what they thought people said I think
the most expensive line is the best the
middle price is the middle and the
cheapest wine was the worst and that's
not that surprising except when the
researchers explained that all three
wines were the same when you raise your
prices a more expensive thing is
perceived in real terms as more valuable
even if the actual core product is the
same the third is results for your
customers if you increase their
emotional investment you increase their
perceived value what ends up happening
they actually do get better results when
they sign up for the gym for personal
training versus a 10 a month thing they
get better results the fourth thing that
happens when you raise your prices you
actually attract less demanding
customers have you ever seen this meme
the customer says well what exactly am I
going to be getting for fifty dollars
then it has the rich customers like wire
set let me know what next steps are
anybody who's ever been in client
services can attest to this the higher
the price tag the more expensive the
contract the fewer payment plans you
have to set up the easier the customer
is to deal with part of the reason that
a 50 person is saying well what exactly
am I be getting if somebody's got a
hundred dollars in their bank account
you're asking for fifty percent of their
net worth just because someone's willing
to pay you doesn't mean that you should
take it the fifth benefit that your
customers will get as a result of
raising your prices is that you actually
have more money you can deliver on your
promises for so imagine you've got a
hard cost thing that costs five bucks
and you charge eight bucks we only have
three dollars left to run the rest of
your business provide service you don't
have a lot of room there now imagine you
charge fifty dollars for that same five
dollar thing you have forty five dollars
that you can now use to deliver two
three four times the value the customer
gets a better experience you can
reinvest in your product you can attract
higher level talent to your business if
you have no margin the best people
aren't going to work for you they're
going to go to the real business owner
who understands how margin needs to work
whereas you're sitting here dealing with
fires all day because of people haggling
over fifty dollars the best way to sell
is having the full conviction that your
product is the best the best quality and
the most elitist product in every line
that we are selling throughout the world
and you can't say your products the best
if you're trying to do it on margin and
you don't have the money to reinvest in
good people you can't do it when you
have all of these higher paying lower
demanding happier your customers your
perception of the real impact you're
actually making goes up it becomes this
snowball that starts rolling and you
have these testimonials and these
reviews that start rolling in the
momentum Builds on the flip side if you
don't have that and it becomes this
Vicious Cycle in the other direction
where you're not getting these
testimonials all you're getting is
chargebacks and refunds from these
demanding customers that had unrealistic
expectations because it was such a high
percentage of their net worth there was
nothing that was going to save them from
themselves there's no advantage to being
the second cheapest person in the
marketplace but there is an advantage to
being the most expensive